[Music]
the sound of explosions over Kiev the
night sky lit up by flashes City
officials say Ukrainian air defense
systems intercepted dozens of Russian
drones and missiles in the early hours
of Tuesday mobile phone footage filmed
by a resident shows the intensity of the
attack
we heard it all even our Windows shook
but thank God there were no missiles in
our area
no my friends my classmates and I we
heard it all they were all worried and
one of my classmates houses got hit I
think it's terrible
the attacks came just hours after
Ukrainian President Vladimir zelenski
returned by train from a trip to Europe
aimed at securing new weapons and
support for an anticipated
counter-offensive
we are returning home with a new
military help newer and more powerful
weapons for the front more protection
for our people greater political support
no one knows when the counter-offensive
will begin but Ukrainian troops are
preparing in the south of the country a
multi-units say they're ready but need
more weapons
offensive because currently we use basic
Jeep models which are not armored an
armored car would provide safety for our
servicemen that's what really matters
even its supporters hope that this
counter-offensive will be successful
since Russia's Invasion Ukrainian forces
have exceeded expectations pressure is
high but the reality is that few believe
that this bush will be the last or will
win the war Natasha Butler Al Jazeera
leviv Ukraine let's all speak to Samuel
Romani who's an associate fellow at the
Royal United Services Institute joining
us from Paris welcome to Al Jazeera so
we saw a large barrage of Russian
missiles overnight and recently there's
been talk of this Ukrainian
counter-offensive how how decisive is
that counter-offensive going to be
so azelinski is not willing to put a
start date on the counter offensive
because he says he needs a bit more time
but I think that there's a lot of
optimism in Kiev that it could be quite
decisive the ukrainians are already
engaging in what the U.S calls shaping
operations which means they're targeting
ammunition Depots logistical sites and
other military targets that would help
them Advance further it looks as if
they're already moving in the directions
as a Parisian Curzon and also parts are
done best right but one thing President
says that more time is needed what are
what are the calculations there what's
he basing that on
well I think it's also to create a bit
of an element of unpredictability right
like over the summer for example
ukrainians may look like that they were
advancing on kurzon and putting all
their resources there and then they
caught the Russians off guard and
defended in car key so the Russian State
media and Russian telegram channels are
really a faint the counter-offensive has
already begun so I think that it's a bit
of psychological operations from Ukraine
a bit of Canada programming to throw the
Russians off had to make them uh miss
their step also I think the ukrainians
are holding out for some more
sophisticated weapon right it was very
encouraging to see France potentially
consider supplying long-range missiles
to Ukraine and the big Target obviously
the ukrainians want are the F-16 Jets
yeah so from a military standpoint and
as those Western countries just pledge
more and more and more military aids to
Ukraine what's your assessment of of
where the where the war will lead to
next
so I think uh the Russian defensive
capabilities have effectively been
blunted it seems as if even on the
flanks of Bachman they're unable to
defend themselves and the Wagner group
is engaging in urban combat over there
in a way that's pretty disjointed and
actually at odds with the Russian
defense minister so it looks as if
Russia is now firmly on the defensive
they've got 152 000 troops and
fortification stationed in separation
karzan there remains to be seen how much
Manpower Ukraine has and how much they
can leverage their technology and also
when critical equipment will arrive the
Abrams Tanks might arrive in 10 weeks
that's an important step forward
hopefully for the ukrainians more
equipment will arrive soon let me ask
you about some another development and
that's that Ukrainian authorities have
detained the head of the Supreme Court
in a high-level corruption probe how
significant is this development
well I think it's quite significant I
think it does lensky is really
emphasized that he ever since the start
of his presidency in 2019 to these
commitment to weeded out we didn't have
corruption wherever he finds it he's
targeted sometimes officials and uh
politicians who have been close to
Russia like Victory Med Chuck and others
but he doesn't want to show that he's
only targeting his political opponents
he also wants to show that he's
targeting uh people within his apparatus
who are corrupt as well so that's why he
went after the Ukrainian defense
Ministry when they had an illegal food
procurement scheme Alexi reznikov the
defense minister almost had to resign
and now they're going after the Supreme
Court in the same way so I think it's
just a way for zelinski to show he's
committed to fighting corruption in
Ukraine whether it be in institutions
that are favorable to him and whether it
be his adversaries at home all right
thank you so much Samuel Romani for
speaking to us from Paris